hello I'm Jessica Clemens and welcome
back to New rockstars Harley Quinn and
the Joker is a new narrative podcast
brought to you by Spotify that follows a
different origin story for our beloved
harleen quinzel where this time she's in
control of the Joker we've heard
different toxic storylines where the
Joker takes full control of Harley but
in this one the rules are reverse this
is no comedy this is a full-on dark
drama and I ate it up Harley Quinn is
played by Christina Ritchie whom you may
know as our old school Wednesday and the
Joker portrayed by Billy Magnuson whom
you may know from game night both do a
spectacular and fun job portraying DC's
prominent super villains this story is
different from the rest of Harley's
actions you'd normally see they capture
her trials as an unappreciated doctor
her motives are very clear and it felt
like you're living in the moment of the
podcast and wandering down Arkham Asylum
living her day-to-day life which made me
appreciate and love her even more than I
already do also can I get a little
commotion for the sound design please
let's get into it
you're listening to Harley Quinn and the
Joker sound mind
[Music]
the first episode immediately pulls you
in with a great thematic song
reminiscent of a troubled love story you
can already see the imagery like red
paint falling down a white wall
outlining harleen slowly changing to
Harley maybe it's just me but the
imagination you're already daydreaming
about immediately hits Harley is on the
phone with her father buying compression
socks you can tell from their phone call
she loves him and is helping him both
financially and assumingly medically as
she refers to her father's doctor Dr
Ramos a lot then the drugstore is
immediately held up at gunpoint
again
this is truly one of my favorite
approaches when we talk about crime in
Gotham it's just another day another day
in a destructive world but harleen
believes it's a world worth fixing
harleen is undoubtedly a hard worker her
colleagues grunfeld played by Stephen
Root and Arnold played by Andre Rio
occasionally stick their noses up to her
at times even joking how Gotham is full
of crime but they don't want to handle
any more folks don't tell Batman we're
full already but you know I I respect
you Harley truly I really really do
you do yeah urban life elbow elbow with
the Untouchable snout in the trough
couldn't handle it myself so son harleen
is completely against and makes her
uncomfortable but how can one react in a
position where they're constantly
undermining you and not only do you want
to work but need to work this job when
asked to go through her roster she
offends though she's helping and offers
alternative methods to really help them
you may know a few of them first we have
Philip R who joined us at Arkham five
months ago his biggest hurdle at the
moment is the hyper vigilance connected
to his synesthetic delusion uh this is
the finger guy I'm sorry finger guy he
believes his optic nerve has channeled
through his hands giving him medication
Philip R is actually the super villain
ten-eyed man former Vietnam War veteran
and security guard who was blinded in an
explosion and reconnected his retinas to
his fingers hence the hyper vigilance
connected to his synesthetic delusions
as harleen says next is Natalya K who
insists that our sessions be held in
complete darkness Natalia K is the super
villain nocturna a jewel thief who
suffered from a rare light sensitivity
disease then they said a very early what
poses you as a threat to Gotham and a
member to Arkham Asylum grunfeld's
three-point discharge rubric all you
need to do is follow my three-point
discharge rubric one do they understand
the moral implications of their crime
too can they control their impulses no
biting no stabbing the basics three do
they have the life skills to effectively
re-enter Society check those three boxes
and we send them straight to the
discharge board which makes no sense
ground frill even lists off super
villains on model compliances Maximilian
Z referring to Maxi Zeus the deluded
millionaire and Waylon Jay AKA Killer
Croc the Killer Croc these callbacks are
fantastic and give you as a listener
time to really understand who's in
Arkham Asylum and who is free but there
are two new faces joining today first
there's Arnold W called shaking down a
taxi stand on the boardwalk where he was
employed as a what was a puppeteer
ventriloquist I believe something anyway
standard disassociative identity
disorder won't talk won't heat refuses
treatment classic shake and bake case if
you ask me
next but you may have read about this
guy in the news pretentious street
performer turned self-proclaimed agent
of chaos keen on large-scale pranks and
Goofs preferred median TNT
real name is currently unknown so we are
going with
patient J for now Arnold W is indeed the
ventriloquist who is usually accompanied
by a companion Scarface and none other
than patient J AKA The Joker immediately
harleen is interested in working with
him figuring out what might be the key
to everyone in Arkham if the number one
super villain is there but they're
concerned that she couldn't handle it as
a woman that could easily fall for the
clown Prince I've dealt with malignant
narcissists before not like this guy
trust me one little bat of the eyelashes
and boom you're trapped inside his awful
little booth did you just think Dr
quinzel patient just got Bob written all
over him later it's proven her esteemed
colleagues couldn't handle the pressure
he cannot
what happened in there what what about
Shake him up
he he is the disease
look send it to blackhead before he
infects everybody in here no well that
would be a little tricky in terms of
paperwork
all those things he said
I'm
I'm a good person
right I know I've made certain mistakes
but I I keep
but fortunately for harleen that's when
things look up she becomes patient J's
newest doctor and we begin the Harley
Quinn and Joker story and officially
meet the Eerie patient Jay
would you like to talk about why you
feel that way
I guess dude
can I get a hug once Harley and the
Joker have their one-on-one they discuss
what happened to the last doctor and
harleen is no nonsense and as we know
the Joker is are you going from my dips
doctor
I think
no
no not today and what are you doing here
I'm just here to listen well I don't
want to talk
I'm thinking you will though
I like you Dr quinzel
much more than Bob much more fun glad to
hear it the Joker's approach to tease
her seduce her press her buttons is
Relentless but harleen is a phenomenal
doctor and keeps that doctor patient
distance you say you're making a big
statement about I don't know capitalism
but all anybody sees is you can I say
doctor
I'm an Entertainer
oh
okay entertain me then
what
how about a joke
a joke well that's kind of your saying
right you won't need to tell you well if
that's a problem I know or no just died
I just need a little oh yeah sure we
know this is a bad romance but note how
harleen is in charge he's fallen for her
methods he's falling for her he's
enticed by her fulfillment as a doctor
and she's amusing him and he's oblivious
to it what's interesting is later Joker
details why he's an Arkham Asylum what
me to Arkham with a large rubber puppet
I'm not sure you know an action figure
accessories sold separately of course
the car the little toys pull the strings
and he sort of growls
come on Doctor you've seen the news yes
Dr quinzel yes yes Batman he brought me
here
referring to the Batman is just another
toy a puppet merely a tool also
signifying he may already know who the
Batman is he's an action figure mocking
his cheap plastic suit accessory sold
separately the car the toys referring to
all the expensive gadgets created just
for him pull the string AKA pushes
buttons and he growls he is nothing but
a toy to the Joker and patient J loves
playing with him and I think he may know
more than he lets on how would you
he's a dancing marionette the eager
brainless defender of business as usual
his strings pulled by the geppettos of
Gotham Wayne and his cronies
show with your boss
I was merely highlighting the wonderful
circle of life here in Gotham what is
Gotham if not a city under higher power
and the grip it has on their super
villains even the Joker shows harleen is
beginning to connect a thread with her
patients and Gotham it leads back to
Batman the beeline of the story is
harling dealing with her father's cancer
that's not getting better and doctors
must work on its stat but she must put
down the down payment before they even
begin working we need to act quickly
how quickly a week at most
okay okay just just let's do it let's
just schedule the operation right right
just uh
as soon as we have that initial payment
I'll get the money
but please can we I'm just I'm afraid
it's Hospital policy we can't conduct
any procedure until we do have that down
payment
I understand
oh thank you
clearly her boiling point is rising
pressure is on heavy she reaches out to
past employers of her father at
Tri-State who refused to believe that
the Hazardous Waste they had gave him
cancer if it's Gotham it always gave
them cancer she calls her aunt who
reminds her that her mother used to lie
and beg for money the same way for drugs
implying why her mom is not with us due
to the drug abuse it begins to feel like
the only place she takes Solace from is
with talking with patient J which well
you know how this is patient Jay what
you're feeling is natural a common
byproduct of the therapeutic setting
but will never make progress if we don't
focus on the matter at hand and what is
you your mental state the moral
implications of your crimes
okay
fine
for you Dr quinfel I'll be a good little
patient Harlan's moves start to prove
themselves when the Joker reveals the
bank robberies and Jewel High star
Child's Play to him uh bank robbery
could anything be more boring
that's boring to you
a bank robbery
I told you I'm not interested in shining
objects wads of grubby cash I educate I
illuminate
so you are saying you could rob a bank
but you just don't want to is that what
I'm hearing it'd be like sleepwalking
through a wet dream
she starts playing real chess taking
back the narrative she's finished trying
to get everyone's assistance she's
putting it into her own hands no matter
how dangerous Troublesome and damaging
the idea is she begins embedding Little
White Lies to Usher her next moves to
help her father what what are you saying
let's see it what you want me to what
are you just another Trevor I'll talk no
action I've seen plenty even [__] a
few
but those days are over what are you
doing what's going on here
tell me what you think is going on here
that's when she plans with the joker to
release him from Arkham Asylum we're
immediately taken to the board of Arkham
Asylum to discuss patient J's release as
long as harleen warns it do you swear
before the Lord that this patient has
the tools and treatment required to
re-enter society as a law-abiding
citizen I uh yes I do
please elaborate for the record I didn't
realize
uh well
I've seen patient J's really just
remarkable progress from an unrepentant
criminal to
um
I mean
just look at him now
clearly uncomfortable
true which yes this is wrong but her
reasoning to save her father trumps that
of her occupation but reassuring doubt
of releasing The Joker wasn't the only
pressure she'd get now the fellow
inmates believe she can fix them just
like she did the Joker which was never
fixed in the first place are we on the
Joker track or what
I'm sorry don't pay attention to him
he's being very rude right now it's
simple you fix the Joker so when are you
fixing us
oh uh well it um
it doesn't work that way
um people are
complicated of course
we understand complicated the joke is
completely cracked but they still got
the yolk back in his head every patient
has different needs but I should be
easier to fix than the Joker
like Dr kunzel later she speaks with her
boss grunfeld who introduces her to
Bruce Wayne and it's her first time
actually meeting him in the series he's
played by Justin Hartley now Bruce likes
to visit because of the uptick in
patience because he sent them there but
no one knows as the Batman she explains
how Batman is the root of the problem
which is truly a valid argument to be
honest Mr Wayne what's in here is just a
reflection of what's out there out there
Gotham Batman
obviously crime in the city is nothing
new but Batman showed up what 18 months
ago
yeah sounds about right whereas the
first of these super villain incidents
wasn't until early this year so you're
suggesting that these Maniacs they're
Batman's fault fault that's above my pay
grade I'm just saying Batman came first
then these guys not the other way around
and now we're triple booked with
patients who are psychotically obsessed
with them everyone has a fixation on
Batman and the crimes didn't reach
astronomical numbers until you arrived
it's like the super villains all have
something to prove now that's when the
television Blair sirens and alarms
interrupting Bruce harleen and the
grunfield's conversation a news anchor
reveals someone just robbed the
Antiquities Museum and it's none other
than the Joker who calls Harley in the
middle of it what is this hello
ah that voice like a square
this is a really bad time for the car
but I have so I really can't talk right
now
stuck in a compromising position hmm
just a little road trip turn on Channel
Nine if you want a bird's eye view of my
activity
I told you I told you a bank job is
Child's Play so I've decided to Pivot to
something with a little more panache
don't worry you'll still get the money
unless you prefer diamond or 10. it's
all very sparkly
that's just the plan is looking
extremely Reckless her voice is doubtful
but she still pushes through the
children are really safe Joker is free
and Harley plans a date with Bruce Wayne
to discuss more about Batman being the
actual problem Bruce Wayne is clearly
involved he's denying Batman as the
problem when all these issues Trail back
to Batman Batman's caught I don't know
dozens of the city's most dangerous
criminals this year right I haven't
really been counting okay well those are
deranged people off the street no longer
a threat to Gotham and finally finally
getting the treatment they need are you
Batman's PR guy or something no look
take Batman out of the equation
completely criminals off the street that
means that there's less it's what I am
saying Batman is the equation he doesn't
understand Harley's patients feel
invisible and worthless while Batman
feels like a star on the front page for
beating up people so they watch and do
the exact same thing the crime the
inequality the hopelessness
swimming every day and no matter what
you do good or bad no one seems to know
this
they feel invisible non-existent
and then Batman appears Larger than Life
splashed across the front pages he gets
noticed so they think I want a piece of
that and they follow his lead she even
notes the similarities between the super
villains and Batman the silly outfit the
gadgets the rivalries they feel noticed
they feel validated by everyone
including Batman she refers to it as a
dance a courtship but since there's only
one Batman there can only be one number
one villain I love this I love this
study I love the in-your-face statistics
of Batman because he needs to know he's
just as important all of this all of
these people are fighting to be at the
top with him the icing on the cake
harleen tells Batman the people of
Gotham need more than a crime fighter
they need support the people of Gotham
they need a champion they need something
to believe in the people of Gotham need
clean drinking water affordable housing
functioning Public Schools a mascot with
a logo is a bit lower classic straw man
no one disagrees with clean drinking
water we do sit down and hear both sides
of the argument because Batman retorts
got man solving clean drinking water
wouldn't be saving the kids from the bus
she agrees cautiously knowing she's the
reason for the robbery and busjacking we
close the third episode with Batman
confirming she's just like the folks of
Gotham and she's normal so that harleen
quinzel replies I'm still young prepping
us for what we're all excited for the
transition from harleen quinzel to
Harley Quinn and the Joker you guys this
series is only the first three episodes
and it's so heavy if you like dramatic
Bad Romance type stories please tune in
if you love Harley Quinn like I do
please tune in the story takes her
places you've never seen before finally
gives her the Reigns listen to Harley
Quinn and the Joker on Spotify make sure
to follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
Lulu underscore Clemons follow new
rockstars subscribe to your access
remember breakdowns of everything you
love thanks for watching bye
foreign